I run here for a cause I run here to
practice my right to movement yes we are
very restricted but by running here and
practicing we prove to the Israeli
occupation that even though that you're
denying us from rest from our rights
movement but we are we are running we're
still here and we're staying here
we also passed by very symbolic places
like the separation wall and two refugee
camps to show the world the daily
struggle of the Palestinians we are
running to tell the world a different
story about the Palestinian in a
positive way and in a peaceful way
I believe in salalah moving st.
Dominic's a little harbour over hospice
for a year